احتماليه الحرب مع حزب الله هي الاعلى منذ
2006 حسب صحيفه يدعوت احرنوت هذا ما حذر
منه مسؤولون امنيون وضباط بالجيش
الاسرائيلي بعد اطلاق عده قذائف من لبنان
باتجاه اسرائيل في الاشهر الاخيره زادت
توتر اثر نصب حزب الله خيمتين قرب الحدود
ازال احداهما وترك الاخرى امام هذا الوضع
تحدث موقع ولا عن خطط عملياتيه اعدها وزير
الدفاع تحسبا لتطهر الاوضاع الامنيه على
الحدود مع لبنان في ظله هذه الاجواء كشفت
صحيفه اسرائيل اليوم عن سيناريو اعده
الجيش الاسرائيلي لحرب محتمله مع حزب الله
في هذا السيناريو يتوقع الجيش ان يطلق حزب
الله ما معدله سته الاف صاروخ يوميا خلال
ايام الحرب الاولى ليتراجع العدد الى ما
بين 1500 صاروخ مع مرور بضعه ايام على
انطلاق الحرب ويتوقع الجيش الاسرائيلي ان
تتوسع رقعه الحرب لتش غزه الذي ستنطلق منه
ايضا صواريخ باتجاه اهداف اسرائيليه هذه
الحرب المحتمله يتوقع الجيش الاسرائيلي ان
توقع 500 قتيل بين المدنيين الاسرائيليين
بالاضافه الى الاف الجرحى دون التطرق الى
الضحايا من العسكريين يتوقع الجيش في هذا
السيناريو اي يواجه صعوبات في حمايه
المواقع الحساسه التي ستكون هدفا للقصف
كمحطات الكهرباء والمصانع ومراكز التمويل
ويتحدث عن اعداد سته عشره كتيبه عسكريه
لتحرير الطرق وتسهيل مرور الجنود والتعامل
مع اضطرابات محتمله ويتخوف الجيش في هذا
السيناريو من شل الحركه في اسرائيل وتوقف
الطيران وانقطاع الكهرباء نتيجه ضرب اهداف
حيويه كمحطات الطاقه ولا يخفي الجيش
الاسرائيلي في هذا السيناريو مخاوفه من
تطوير خصومه اسلحتهم التي اصبحت اكثر دقه
ويستشهد بالفعاليه التي اظهرتها مسيرات
ايران في حرب اوكرانيا وحسب صحيفه اسرائيل
اليوم فانما يحمله هذا السيناريو من مخاوف
هو ما دفع الجيش الى ضبط النفس امام عده
احداث على الحدود مع لبنان مؤخرا